disney's hip musical encanto is loaded
with easter eggs and references
including frozen tangled and hercules
plus secret clues that predict the
movie's ending yipikai movie lovers i'm
jan and in this video i'm revealing the
top 50 things you missed and details to
look out for in encanto spoilers ahead
so take care this video is sponsored by
omaze for a chance to win a
multi-million dollar dream house in la
go to omaze.com flicks to highlight the
ambiguity and mystery around bruno's
character the filmmakers used a lot of
green when he's on screen so when he
pops up for the first time and we don't
talk about bruno the lighting of the
scene instantly changes to green and
mirabelle's link to him is hinted at via
her green coloured glasses and skirt as
well as her door and room foreshadowing
the fact that she'll uncover the truth
and end the family's silence about her
missing uncle and there's a clue to
bruno's power to see the future when
mirabelle goes into his tower the
entrance to which is shaped like an
hourglass hourglasses are used to
measure time so it's fitting the film
often uses them for instance on bruno's
door and his poncho as signs of his
ability to see through the sands of time
and into the future louise's song
surface pressure is a lot of fun with
many great visuals and hilarious dancing
donkeys which remind me of the singing
reindeers in kristoff's frozen two songs
as well as featuring a reference to the
titanic the song also includes a shout
out to the myth of hercules which disney
adapted for its own animated movie when
louisa fights the three-headed hound
cerberus a cool bonus detail you might
have missed is the crowd of donkey
spectators in the background watching
her in the arena also the split in the
ground beneath louisa foreshadows the
cracks that later appear in the house
and also how the mountains behind the
casita split in two as the house begins
to fall apart
the filmmakers chose pastel and pink
colours for isabella's clothes and room
to give her a princess vibe to go with
her reputation as a senorita perfecta
did someone say
flowers
please don't clap but after she breaks
out of that unwanted role isabella sheds
that image opting for more vibrant
colors instead at the start of the movie
antonio's outfit is white to show that
he hasn't got his abilities yet he's a
blank slate powers-wise however
afterwards his clothes become more
colourful and features some of the
creatures he can communicate with the
outfits worn by all the family are also
colour coordinated to reflect the
different branches of the madrigal
family tree mirabelle has sisters and
parents are dressed in cool tones blues
purples and greens while peppa her
husband and kids are dressed in warmer
tones such as oranges yellows and reds
there's a fun moment in the first song
the family madrigal when the three
village kids demand to know all the
family's powers tell us what everyone
can do and that's why coffee's for
grown-ups it's more than just an amusing
joke though because in colombia it's not
uncommon for kids to drink coffee though
it's generally not very strong
after antonio gets his gift and opens
the door to its magical world the
villagers are invited inside and as the
excitable kids enter one of them
exclaims it's bigger on the inside a hat
tip to doctor who and what people often
say when they first enter the tardis
the expansive area behind each door
reflects each character's magical power
and personality and is inspired by
magical realism in fact encanto pays
special tribute to colombian author
gabrielle garcia marquez known for the
magical realism in his stories the
yellow butterflies in the film are a
homage to the ones that appear in one of
his best-known novels a hundred years of
solitude there's also a butterfly motif
on abuela's enchanted candle and when
the casita is first created butterflies
magically appear a yellow butterfly also
appears when bruno creates a new vision
for mirabelle and a swarm of them form
where mirabelle and abuela reconcile by
the river there are also numerous
butterflies hidden in the background of
the movie from mirabelle's recordian to
the casitas doorknocker to the wallpaper
inside mirabelle's room and the
butterfly pattern in the walls of the
house abuela also has one on a brooch he
wears and mirabelle has many on her
outfit one of the filmmakers has said
that the butterfly's wings represent a
bit of magic that is directly linked to
the candle that originally brought the
miracle to the family more generally as
well butterflies often symbolise
transformation freedom and new
beginnings which also fits the story of
the madrigal family and their home
there's a sneaky frozen easter egg in
kanto but just before i reveal that if
you'd like a magical dream house of your
own thanks to our sponsor omaze you have
the chance to win this luxurious 5
bedroom 6 bathroom house in la with
in-home movie theater heated pool bar
sports court and home gym this 4.3
million home in the city of angels is
among the latest one-of-a-kind prizes
that omaze gives away while donating
money to chosen charities around the
world and it comes complete with an open
concept living room and kitchen perfect
for entertaining friends and family plus
la's beaches and vibrant nightlife are
just minutes away for your chance to win
this stunning house or three million
dollars in cash go to
omaze.comflix to donate and support
rebuilding together a charity devoted to
repairing the homes of veterans people
with disabilities and low-income
families the charity's long-term
projects include revitalizing entire
neighborhoods by improving parks schools
community centres and non-profit
facilities so for your chance to win
this dream house and support a great
cause go to
amaze.comflix to donate when bruno
returns to the family and the song all
of you he raps a little then gives a
nice tribute to elsa's iconic let it go
moment in frozen as he sings let it snow
let it go and showers himself with salt
to mimic snow falling this one might be
a little stretch but i got some rapunzel
vibes from isabella whenever she swung
around on vines created from her magical
gift similar to how rapunzel was
swinging around on her magical hair
entangled mirabelle's mother julieta has
a special power to heal physical
ailments with her food you just healed
my hand with an alle pacon queso and
this is very tricky to spot but in her
kitchen there are some books one of
which is titled
which in english means beer for
headaches the deliberately diy
customized look of mirabelle's outfit
reflects her personality and desperate
desire to be noticed among a family of
super gifted individuals as well as her
own name and picture her highly
embroidered skirt blouse and bag include
shout outs to her loved ones for abuela
there's a candle for peppa a rainbow as
well as a sun and rain cloud various
flowers for her sister isabella an arm
holding up a weight for her sister
louisa a variety of animals such as
snakes and caffey barras for cousin
antonio and a chameleon for camilo and
there's even a note that she loves her
family in there as for mirabelle's
glasses according to the film team
they're part of the storytelling as a
key theme of the movie is perception and
perspective and the role it plays in
family dynamics in other words as one of
the production designers says it's about
how two people can view the same
situation completely differently and how
those different points of view can
affect their relationship on top of that
mirabelle's whole look including her
glasses meant a lot to actress stephanie
beatrice who also wore glasses growing
up and sees a lot of herself in the
character so much so that she started
crying the first time she saw mirabelle
brought to life
when lim manuel miranda sat down to
write the family madrigal he was
especially inspired by the much-loved
opening number from beauty and the beast
belle just like belle family madeligal
gives us a ton of information in a
relatively short amount of time and also
just like the first song in beauty and
the beast presents its main characters
and townsfolk giving us insight into
their roles in the movie so too
encanto's opening number introduces us
to three generations of the madrigal
family and also shows us how they
interact with people in their village
each character's magical gift is also
reflected in their clothing and you can
catch a lot more details about the
characters and their development in the
art of encanto book isabella's flower
power is shown through her dress which
is layered to give the feel of petals
while colombia's national flower the
orchid is embroidered around her
neckline luisa's outfit features weights
which represent her super strength also
look out for raindrops on their aunt
peppa's dress as well as lightning bolts
and her little sun earrings all of which
represent her ability to control the
weather with her emotions julieta has
lots of herbs in her clothes which are
nod to her power of healing through her
cooking and although her husband
agustine doesn't have any powers of his
own to illustrate on his outfit he does
have little hat tips to his three
daughters with a flower from isabella
and his lapel and one sock patterned
with barbells for louisa and the other
embroidered with many things including
butterflies for mirabelle as for peppa's
husband felix according to the
filmmakers the triangles and other
geometric shapes on his outfit represent
his stability and support for his family
and his gifted son camilo's clothes
feature chameleons on his poncho and
sandals which fits his shape-shifting
powers
as the head of the madrigal family
awola's room is at the center of the
house and opposite hers is mirabelle's
room which highlights their connection
and foreshadows the end of the movie as
both women are central to the creation
of the casita but the position of the
rooms also points to their opposite
opinions as well with abuela desperately
trying to hold on to the past and how
things have been while mirabelle sees
things must change for a better future
for everyone
actor alan tudyk voices the toucan in
the movie
uh-huh uh-huh i understand you and after
also lending his voice to animations
including the wreck-it ralph movies
hello my loyal subjects big hero 6. i
love that robot frozen the duke of
weaseltown
zootopia it's weaselton duke weaselton
moana
and roya and the last dragon
he's fast becoming disney's equivalent
to pixar's good luck charm john
ratzenberger
and when i was looking out for hidden
mickeys i wondered whether this cactus
that isabella creates could be one let
me know what you think and if you
spotted any others so who are your
favorite characters in encounter and did
you notice any other easter eggs tell me
in the comments below thanks to omaze
for sponsoring this video go to
omaze.comflix for a chance to win this
incredible la dream house don't forget
to like and subscribe if you enjoyed
this video and you can tap left for my
next disney video including all the
deleted scenes from raya and the last
dragon thanks for watching and see you
next time yupikai movie lovers